Schön.
Ja, hallo, guten Tag.
Guten Tag.
Ich bin Erdemüser und auf dieser Station als Assistant Arztetik.
Für Sie bin ich heute der zuständige Arzt.
Deswegen möchte ich mit Ihnen das auchnahmegeschritt durchführen.
Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja, natürlich. Hauptsache mir hilft jemand.
Okay.
Zuerst stelle ich einige Fragen für Ihre persönlichen Daten
und dann sprechen wir Ihre aktuellen Beschwerden ausführlich.
Okay.
Ja, okay.
Bitte sagen Sie mir Bescheid oder fragen Sie danach,
wenn Sie etwas nicht verstehen.
Okay.
Wie heißen Sie den?
Ich heiße Kurt Bergmann.
Könnten Sie bitte Ihren Vor- und Nachnamen bestabieren?
Der Vorname ist K-U-R-T, Kurt.
Und der Familienname ist B-E-R-G-M-A-Doppel-N, Bergmann.
Okay.
Herr Bergmann, ja?
Mhm.
Okay.
Herr Bergmann, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin, ich muss Sie gerade rechnen, ich bin 54 Jahre alt.
Wann genau sind Sie geboren?
Am 15.03.68.
15.03.68.
60.
Mhm.
Okay.
Wie schwer und wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 175 groß und wiege so 80 Kilo.
80 Kilo und 1 Meter.
Wie groß sind Sie?
1 Meter 75.
75, okay.
Was sind Sie vom Beruf?
Ich arbeite als Tierpfleger ins Zoo.
Tierpfleger, okay.
Wie ist Ihr Familienstand?
Ich bin verheiratet.
Okay, haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, wir haben drei Kinder.
Die sind jetzt zwar schon ziemlich groß, aber sie sind noch alle im Haus.
Okay, alles klar.
Sie wohnen mit Ihrer Familie, Ihrer Frau?
Mit der Familie zusammen, ja.
Mhm.
Okay.
Herr Bergmann, was kann ich für Sie tun?
Welche Beschwerden haben Sie im Moment?
Ich habe wahnsinnige Schmerzen in meinem rechten Handgelenk.
Jetzt muss ich dazu sagen, ich bin vorhin mit meinem Motorrad hingefallen.
Jetzt ist ja so schönes Wetter, dann will man mal raus.
Und da war irgendwas Sand auf der Straße oder was.
Und da bin ich halt gestürzt.
Und bin ja offensichtlich auf die rechte Hand gefallen.
Helm hatte ich natürlich auf, also dem Kopf ist irgendwo nichts passiert.
Aber ich bin irgendwie so auf die rechte Seite gefallen.
Und also das Handgelenk, erst habe ich gedacht, es ist nicht so schlimm,
aber das wurde jetzt in der letzten Stunde immer schlimmer.
Und dann bin ich eben doch hierher gekommen.
Und ja, ich glaube, ich habe auch so, so an den rechten,
so im Rustkorb habe ich glaube ich auch ein bisschen was abgekriegt.
Da habe ich so blaue Flecken und da ist auch die Haut ein bisschen weg.
Und ja, also ich kann mich eigentlich da nicht so gut bewegen.
Und was mir aufgefallen ist, wenn ich also so richtig tief einatme,
dann tut mir das auch ein bisschen weh.
Okay. Wann genau ist der Unfall passiert?
Das ist so zweieinhalb Stunden her.
Und eigentlich ist nichts kaputt gewesen.
Also am Motorrad war nichts kaputt.
Ich habe auch an der Straße nichts kaputt gemacht.
Ich habe also keine Polizei geholt.
Aber jetzt, diese Hand, das eben sehr schmerzhaft.
Okay.
Nach dem Unfall haben Sie der Seite Luftnot.
Bitte.
Ja, also es tut mir Luft.
Oder Luft?
Aber es tut weh beim Einatmen.
Ja, es tut weh beim Einatmen so.
Okay. Wohin sind die Schmerzen in der Brust?
Hinter den Brustbein oder?
Nein, da sind sie nicht.
Eigentlich mehr so einer Seite, da wo ich auch draufgefallen bin.
Auf der rechten Seite.
Aber sie sind auf der rechten Seite gestürzt.
Gestürzt? Auf der rechten Seite gestürzt, ja.
Ihre Schulter ist auch betrunken.
Nein, die Schulter hat glaube ich nix abgekriegt.
Die Schulter ist okay, nur das Handgelenk.
Vielleicht habe ich mich mit dem Handschuh,
das Handgelenk ist irgendwie abgestürzt.
Aber Sie hat den Schützkleidungen und so weiter.
Ich hatte Schützkleidungen, ja.
Ja, in meinem Alter und mit Familie,
da kann man nicht ohne Schützkleidung Motorrad fahren.
Und Helm ist auch da?
Helm, ja.
Okay, wie stammt sind die Schmerzen auf einer Skala von 1 bis 10,
wobei ein sehr leichter und sehr, sehr stärker Schmerzen
entspricht?
Also die Schmerzen in der Hand sind wirklich heftig.
Die sind bestimmt bei 7 bis 8.
Okay, in der Brust?
Auf der Brust haben Sie keine Schmerzen, ja?
Nicht so stark.
Also vielleicht so bei 5, 4, 5 oder so,
beim Einatmen halt insbesondere so,
also ob sich gegen die Dehnung so ein bisschen wehrt.
Wie sind die Schmerzen stechend, brennend?
Im Handgelenk, da sind die, wie sind die denn?
Ich kann das schwer beschreiben.
Das ist stechend, aber auch stechend, drückend,
ja sowieso ein Verreißschmerz eigentlich so ein bisschen.
Ich kann das nicht gut beschreiben, wie das ist.
Also es tut jedenfalls sehr weh.
Schmerzen trafen die Schmerzen irgendwo hin aus?
Nein, nein, das ist aufs Handgelenk eigentlich.
Also klar ist natürlich die ganze Hand jetzt inzwischen geschwollen
und ich kann das auch überhaupt nicht bewegen,
aber die Schmerzen strahlen nicht so richtig aus.
Und zur Mitte Seite sind die Schmerzen verschillend, ja?
Ja, auf alle Kellen.
Haben Sie etwas dagegen eingenommen, ein Medikament?
Nein, ich habe gedacht, ich komme lieber erst hier zu Ihnen,
damit Sie das abklären können.
Okay, sind die Schmerzen dauerhaft oder kommen Sie ab und zu
und dann gehen Sie wieder?
Nein, die Schmerzen in der Hand sind wirklich dauerhaft
und ja, die werden jetzt auch wirklich unangenehm.
Mhm.
Derzeit können Sie die Hand nicht richtig und gut bewegen, ja?
Nee, gar nicht.
Ich muss sie auch so ein bisschen festhalten,
so mit der anderen Hand, ne?
Weil das einfach alles schmerzt.
Okay.
Und Luftnote haben Sie immer?
Nein, ich habe keine Luft nun, ich kriege ja Luft.
Ich merke es nur, wenn ich versuche,
viel einzuatmen, dann merke ich, dass das weh tut.
Okay.
Aber so bei flacher Atmung passiert nichts.
Mhm, okay.
Sie können Luft kriegen, aber dabei gibt es besonders beim
Einatmen, haben Sie Schmerzen, ja?
Genau.
Und dann haben Sie Fieber oder Schütterfrust?
Nee.
Schwitzen Sie nicht?
Schwitze auch nicht, nee.
Mhm.
Haben Sie Überallkeit?
Ja, so, von den Schmerzen ist mir jetzt so ein bisschen schlecht,
würde ich sagen, aber ich glaube, das ist mehr so der Schreck,
der mir noch in den Knochen sitzt.
Mhm.
Dass ich jetzt so ein bisschen aufgeregt bin auch und,
dass mir so ein bisschen überlässt.
Okay, Erbürochen haben Sie?
Nee, übergeben muss ich mich nicht, nein.
Durchfallverstopfung haben Sie?
Ich habe tatsächlich Durchfall, ja.
Mhm, okay.
Seit wann?
Ich glaube, das ist jetzt, also das habe ich leicht mal,
wenn ich ein bisschen aufgeregt bin oder so.
Und ich glaube, das ist jetzt, also sowieso auch, ne?
Seitdem umfalkönen wir sagen oder früher hatten Sie auch?
Nein, ich habe das eigentlich immer, wenn es ein bisschen Stress gibt.
Okay, beim Stress, ja.
Okay, war Ihnen schwindelig oder schwarz vor den Augen?
Nein.
Ich bin nur ausgerutscht.
Haben Sie das Babystein verloren?
Nein.
Dann wäre ich ja nicht mehr nach Hause gekommen.
Mhm, okay.
Und haben Sie sonst noch etwas Ungewöhnliches bemerkt?
Nee, aber das, was ich bemerkt habe, reicht mir eigentlich.
Also die Schmerzen da in der Hand, ne?
Und eben, ja, dass ich so blaue Flecken habe,
das ist schon unangenehm.
Mhm.
Haben Sie offene Verletzungen derzeit oder Volutungen?
Wie gesagt, ich habe so ein bisschen,
am Brustkorb habe ich das gemerkt, dass durch die Kleidung,
durch das so ein bisschen die Haut abgeschrappt ist
und dass ich da auch ja jetzt schon blaue Flecken habe.
Okay, am Brustkorb auch, ja?
Mhm, genau.
Okay, leiten Sie an chronischen Erkrankungen?
Ja, also...
Beispielweise Bluthoffdruck, blutrücker Krankheit?
Nee, ganz geniegendteil, ich habe niedrigen Blutdruck von 10 Jahren,
und das ist ja eigentlich, hat man eigentlich selten, ja?
Und was ich tatsächlich habe,
ein Bandscheibenvorfall in der Halswirbelsäule,
und da habe ich jetzt auch manchmal so ausstrahlende Schmerzen
in die rechte Schulter,
aber das ist jetzt beim Unfall nicht irgendwie verändert.
Und was ich noch habe, das ist Neurodermitis.
Ich habe das als Kind in den Ellenbäugen gehabt,
und jetzt inzwischen ist es eigentlich mehr so außen an den Oberarmen,
dass ich da so trockene Hautstellen habe,
und da muss ich zwischendurch mal Cortisonse auftragen.
Okay, Sie leiten an Bluthoffdruck seit 10 Jahren?
Niedrigem Blutdruck.
Niedrigem?
Ja, okay, niedrigem, ja.
Und da habe ich so einen Medikament, ich weiß aber nicht, wie das heißt,
das sind so Tropfen, die muss ich nehmen,
wenn ich merke, dass der zu weit unten ist.
Was nehmen Sie genau?
Wie das heißt, weiß ich nicht.
Ein Tropfen, ja?
Und seit 10 Jahren,
und Bandscheibenvorfall, wann haben Sie bemerkt,
oder seit wann haben Sie?
Den habe ich seit 5 Jahren.
Und Neurodermitis, seit wann haben Sie?
Seit der Kinderzeit.
Nehmen Sie regelmäßig Medikamente?
Ja, eben diese Tropfen, weil bedarf,
und die Cortisonseilbe auch, weil bedarf.
Und wenn ich irgendwie mal Schmerzen habe,
und ich muss erarbeiten gehen, dann nehme ich Ibuprofen.
Okay.
Sind Sie schon einmal operiert worden?
Ja, also eine ganz kleine Operation vor 5 Jahren,
da ist eine Stereolisation durchgeführt worden.
Und dann hatte ich vor 25 Jahren
einen Sportunfall, da hatte ich ein Achilleszenenriss,
und das ist operativ versorgt worden.
Ja, ich habe nicht verstanden,
könnten Sie bitte wiederholen, die Operationen?
Also die erste OP, das ist vor 5 Jahren gewesen,
das war ein kleiner Eingriff zur Stereolisation.
Stereolisation, okay.
Und vor 25 Jahren hatte ich ein Sportunfall,
und da hatte ich ein Achilleszenenriss,
und der ist operativ versorgt worden.
Die Achilleszene,
ist die große Szene am hinteren Fuß?
Okay, hinter dem Fuß, ja.
Okay, ist bei Ihnen eine Allergie bekannt
gegen bestimmte Medikamente?
Ja, tatsächlich.
Ich bin gegen Kontrastallerg, das darf ich nicht bekommen.
Was ist das Kontrastmittel gegen?
Ich habe nur gesammelt, kein Kontrastmittel.
Okay, wie oisert sich diese Allergie?
Ja, ich habe da mal so Hitzegefühl bekommen,
und das Gesicht wurde ganz rot,
und ich habe auch ein bisschen Herzklopfen gehabt.
Dann sollte ich das nicht wieder machen.
Okay, alles klar.
Okay, gibt es Ihnen Ihre Familie,
wichtige Erkrankungen, von denen ich wissen sollte?
Ich meine bei Ihren Eltern,
Ihren Geschwistern und Ihren Kindern, ja?
Die Kinder sind zum Glück gesund.
Mein Vater hatte vor zehn Jahren die Herzinfarktung,
ist gestorben, da war er noch nicht alt,
da war er 68, kann das stimmen?
Ja, gut, von mir aus.
Und meine Mutter, die ist eigentlich gesund.
Sie hat jetzt nur so einen anderen Schlefe,
an einer Seite hat sie einen weißen Hautkrebs,
und das ist operativ entfernt worden.
Aber jetzt ist sie gesund?
Ja, das gilt als geheilt so.
Da wird nichts weiter gemacht.
Okay, haben Sie in letzter Zeit ungewollt,
ab oder so genommen?
Ich meine in den letzten Wochen oder Monaten.
Nein, nein, nein.
Wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Der ist immer gut.
Außer heute jetzt, aber normal ist er immer gut.
Okay, rauchen Sie?
Ja, nicht mehr viel.
Ich habe früher lange Jahre ein Päckchen am Tag geraucht,
aber seit vier Jahren habe ich das deutlich reduziert.
Das brauche ich nur noch 50er Retten am Tag.
Aber früher hatten Sie ein Packung pro Tag,
und wie viel Jahre dauerte es?
20 Jahre.
Okay, hier kennen Sie Alkohol?
Ja, Alkohol, jeden Abend Bier.
Das trinke ich wohl, ja.
Eine Flasche?
Eine Flasche Bier am Abend, ja.
Haben Sie schon einmal Drogen probiert?
Das ist eine Routinefrage.
Eine Erfahrung damit? Nein, kann ich nicht mit Ihnen? Nein.
Okay.
Herr Bertmann, meiner Meinung nach habe ich alle wichtigen Informationen erhalten.
Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Ja, ich möchte jetzt nur, dass jemand mal nach meiner Hand guckt.
Wie bitte?
Ich möchte jetzt nur, dass jemand, ich meine, nach meiner Hand guckt.
Ja, nicht nur Ihrer Hand,
sondern auch Ihrer Lunge Kuchenbier.
Ja, eigentlich ist die Hand nicht so wichtig,
sondern die Königin ist möglich, das stabilisieren.
Aber Brüsch im Essen sind eigentlich wichtig.
Okay.
Und dann, deswegen sollten Sie hier bleiben.
Ich lege einen Zugang und dann nehme gleichzeitig Blut ab.
Ja, darüber hinaus melde ich für Röntgenaufnahme an.
Von der Hand oder was?
Von der Hand und natürlich vom Brust.
Ah, okay.
Von der Brust, ja.
Und dann in Ihrem Falle besprechen ich natürlich mit meinem Oberast.
Und nachdem ich alle Ergebnisse bekomme,
komme ich wieder zu Ihnen.
Ja, okay, gut.
Und dann gibt es noch etwas,
über das wir nie gesprochen haben.
Alles in Ordnung?
Ich meine, wir haben ziemlich viel gesagt.
Hat jemand noch Ideen?
Das Einzige, was Sie nicht gefragt haben,
das aber jetzt irgendwie so der heutigen Zeit halt geschuldet,
ist Impfstatus, ne?
Impfstatus haben Sie nicht gefragt.
Ja, Impfstatus, ja, genau.
Zum ersten Mal mache ich diese Übung.
Deswegen unter der Fall.
Eigentlich gibt es nicht nur einen Fall,
sondern auch zwei Fälle Unfall.
Und ja, Brust.
Ja, aber ich schlage es wegen Corona.
Wegen Corona muss man das heute nicht fragen.
Ja, ja, ja, das ist der Wichtigste.
Aber ich wüsste hier auch.
Das ganze Spektrum abgefragt.
Ja, möchte ich jetzt von den Kollegen jemand was sagen dazu?
Wann erfolgte Ihre letzte Tetanus-Impfung?
Oh, gute Frage.
Ja, da sind wir beim Impfstatus.
Oh, das ist schon lange her.
Das ist schon sehr lange her.
Das ist sicherlich auffrischungsbedürftig, ja.
Guter Tipp, danke.
Deswegen würde ich ja sagen,
ich habe noch eine Impfung gegen Tetanus direkt hier.
Dann bin ich auch mit einverstanden, ja.
Gut, brauchen Sie noch ein bisschen Zeit,
bis Sie das Gespräch mit dem Oberarzt haben?
Oder wollen Sie gleich loslegen?
Ja, wir können.
Wir können gleich.
Ich hoffe, ja.
Ja, super, ich hoffe.
Okay.
Hallo, guten Abend, Herr Frau Oberarztin.
Hallo.
Ja, heute habe ich einen neuen Patienten,
nämlich Kurt Bergmann, aufgenommen.
Und mit Ihnen möchte ich diesen Patienten besprechen.
Hätten Sie dafür kurz Zeit?
Ja, natürlich. Was ist denn mit Herrn Bergmann?
Herr Bergmann ist ein 54-jähriger Patient
und stellt sich bei uns wegen vor zwei Stunden
aufgetreten den Unfall vor.
Ein Motorunfall?
Nein, ein Motorunfall.
Ein Motorunfall, ja.
Okay.
Sie wissen sieben und acht von zehn
und in der Brust sie wissen vier und fünf auf der Skala.
Und der Patient klagt über mehr die Schmerzen,
besonders in den Handgelenk.
Aber in der Brust schmerzen leichter.
Aber die Brust schmerzen
würden generell beim Einatmen auftreten.
Aber sie haben auch Bemerkthei Patient,
haben auch Hematom am Handgelenk
in der Brust bemerkt.
Mhm.
Und dann, diese Schimmersen würden in einer anderen Region nicht ausgetracht werden.
Und wegen der Schimmersen können die Patienten handgelackt nicht bewegen.
Und mit der Zeit hätten diese Schimmersen besonders handgelackt sich verschlimmert.
Ja, sehr gut.
Aber dagegen habe er nichts eingenommen.
Sie wollten direkt zu uns kommen.
Kann ich mich auch.
Mhm.
Ja, genau.
Und die Schimmersen seien immer dauerhaft.
Bis auf Überkeit besonders beim Stress war die vegetative Anamnesen unauffällig.
Kein Erbrechen, aber nur Durchfall habe er auf.
Besonders beim Stress.
Jetzt habe er auch Überkeit.
Mhm.
Und dann, ja, seit 100 Jahren habe er, vor Erkrankungen, habe er Hypotony.
Und dagegen nehme ...
Hypotony.
Hypotony, ja, gerne, Hypotony.
Und dagegen nehme er bei Bedarf Tropfen.
Mhm.
Und seit fünf Jahren habe er Diskusprolapsus.
Auf welcher Höhe, auf welcher Höhe, auf welcher Höhe den Diskusprolaps?
Ja, bei Hilfswirbelsäule, ja.
Mhm.
Okay, Kolumnevertebralis, Pars servicalis.
Mhm, genau.
Und seit Kinder heute habe er Neuradermatitis und dagegen nehme er bei Bedarf Cortison, ja.
Mhm.
Cortison-Salve.
Ja, Cortison-Salve.
Kein, kein, das ist das themisches Cortison, ne?
Nein, nein, nein, ja, kein Medikament, ja.
Salve, genau.
Mhm.
Und dann vor fünf Jahren, ja, vor fünf Jahren wurde bei ihm Sterilisation als OP gemacht.
Und zweimal vor fünf und vor zehn Jahren, vor 20 Jahren, habe er Sportunfall.
Und deswegen musste er bei Aschil Tendon, als OP-Tour.
Ach, das sehen wir in der OP-Tour.
Mhm.
Okay.
Und dann gegen Kontrastmittel reagiere er sich, ja, oder auf Kontrastmittel sei er reagierig.
Sei er allergisch?
Ja, sei er allergisch mit Hitze, ja, Hitze, Rötung beim Gesicht und Herzkröten, ja.
Mhm.
Als Familienanamnese kann ich so sagen, ja, Mutter sei gesund, aber wegen des Hautkrebs
musste sie operiert, musste sie operiert werden.
Und der Vater sei gestorben mit 68 wegen Herzinfarkts.
Mhm.
Und dann, okay, er rauchte, er rauchte, der sei nicht so viel, fünf Zigarette pro Tag, seit vier
Jahren, aber früher hatte er viel, hätte er viel geraucht, ein Papier pro Tag, ja, 21
Pakungsjahren kann ich so sagen.
Mhm.
Und dann, Alkohol trinke er eine Flasche Bier abends.
Die Fragen nach Drogen wurden verneint, ja, das sind so, ja, das ist so.
Ich habe diese Fragen gestellt und diese Informationen habe ich erhalt.
Was ist denn jetzt Ihre Verdachtstheorinose?
Ja, meine Verdachtstheorinose ist eigentlich pulmonary Emboli und Fraktur am
Handgeleg.
Okay, ja, einer sieht das aus.
Und wegen Handfraktur, wegen Handfraktur gibt es wahrscheinlich Fettemboli in den
Lungen.
Ah, spannende Idee, ja, okay.
Mhm.
Okay.
Und deswegen würde ich stationär aufnehmen.
Mhm.
Und dann ja, natürlich, einen Zugang lege ich ab und Blut, ja, lege ich Zugang und dann
gleichzeitig Blut ab und einige Parameter, Blutparameter würde ich kontrollieren.
Ja, was würden Sie denn genau, was würden Sie im Labor angreizen?
Ja, der Patient braucht wahrscheinlich eine OP, deswegen wäre es besser, ja,
Blutbild, Einstellungsparameter, CRP und BSG, Lebewerte, Nierenwerte.
Und natürlich für Emboli ist das sehr wichtig, Dedimer.
Mhm.
Und für fragliche blutige Operationen?
Äh natürlich, Blutgruppe?
Blutgruppe?
Blutgruppe.
Blutgruppe, Brotblut, ja.
Blutung seit Protod pigsat aktivitier guitars, ja genau,
Seit langer Zeit sei der Patient nicht geimpft gegen Tethanus, deswegen würde ich Tethanus machen.
Gut.
Als Bilkebende-Verfahren würde ich natürlich röntgen am Handgelenk und röntgen natürlich in der Brust röntgen.
Wie heißt das denn offiziell?
Toraxonöntgen.
Ja, in zwei Ebenen.
Und PA und seitlich würde ich auch ja.
Das ist auch wichtig und bei der Wahrscheinlich können wir auch Ski-Tee anfertigen.
Ah ja, okay.
Das wäre wahrscheinlich besser.
Was lassen Sie denn über den Zugang laufen?
Söerst würde ich Navarumskarrense anordnen und dann natürlich Kontrollen, die alle Vitalparameter, Tension, Fieber und so weiter.
Und dann, ja, eine Sodium-Klöhrer kann ich ja.
Eine was?
Ja, Flüssigkeit als Flüssigkeit.
Flüssigkeit, ja, und der Manager-Schmerzen?
Ja, ich möchte auch besser, sehr gut.
Und ich würde Metamizol geben, ja.
Oder bei Bedarf Morphin kann ich auch geben.
Und ja, was machen Sie noch?
Sie stellen den Patienten ruhig und Sie haben...
Ja, der Patient sollte ruhig bleiben.
Deswegen würde ich auch bei Angst, kann ich auch Diasen geben, oder?
Ja, ich dachte jetzt eigentlich an etwas anderes.
Einmal muss natürlich irgendwie diese Hand, wie auch immer mit der Tabellisierung.
Ja, und hochgelagert und kühlt werden je nachdem.
Genau.
Aber der Patient wird ja jetzt relativ immobilisiert.
Was brauchen Sie da noch?
Derzeit ist er immobilisiert, deswegen sollen wir machen, Oberkörper sollen wir bis hoch.
Wegen der potentiellen Luft und ich denke an etwas ganz Banales.
Das habe ich gerade den Text mit gelesen.
Ja, okay, okay, ja, das war es.
Ja, ganz sehr wichtig.
TVT-Profilaxe, ne?
Ja, Heparin, ja, 5000.
Und wirklicherweise eben auch tatsächlich eine Strümpfe an, ne?
Bei Betrugung, Kompressionsstrümpfe.
Ja, ganz wichtig.
Okay, gut.
Ja, dann bin ich gespannt, was bei Ihrer Untersuchung rauskommt.
Halten Sie mich auf dem Laufenden, was mit Herrn Bergmann passiert?
So, ja, also ganz ehrlich, für erste Ananese, haben wir gut.
Richtig, richtig gut.
Ja, und ich weiß, dass diese Trauma...
Ich konnte nicht gut strukturieren eigentlich, ich konnte nicht gut strukturieren, aber...
Doch, war alles, war alles.
Ja, also ich weiß, dass die Traumapazienten generell nicht besonders beliebt sind, ja, als Fallbeispiele.
Aber es gibt sie ja nun mal.
So, das ist das eine.
Und was ich immer nicht weiß, ja, in solch einem Fall, es geht ja tatsächlich um die Unfallfolgen.
Wie relevant ist die Frage nach der Familienananese?
Wie relevant ist die Frage, na gut, wenn der Schmerzen beim Einatmen hat, dann ist die Frage nach Rauch,
und natürlich schon irgendwie relevant.
Und wenn man natürlich nach Alkohol fragt und der hat den Verkehrsunfall, also Motorradunfall,
ist natürlich auch die Frage nach Alkohol irgendwo interessant.
Ja, beim Unfall sollte man sich möglichst den Patienten behandeln.
Eigentlich diese anonystische Fragen, einige von ihnen sind nicht relevant, aber wegen der Prüfung fragen wir...
Ja, ich weiß, das sage ich immer wieder. Die Prüfung ist keine reale Situation.
Absolut, ja, absolut.
Oder bei der Prüfung können wir auch diese sagen, ja.
Normalerweise, wenn ich einen solch einen Fall in der Klinik hätte, würde ich so, so, so machen.
Aber trotzdem sollte ich machen, ja, aber weiter machen.
Ja, ganz genau. Das ist der Königsweg, ja. Also da machen sie alles richtig.
Und keiner kann Ihnen sagen, ja, hätten, hätten, der Mann ist ja schon längst tot, ja.
Normalerweise ist es schön, dass man den Patienten stabilisieren oder Gips oder Tracks ört.
Ja, monitoren.
Man hat absolut die Monitoren.
Ja.
Schön ist es möglich.
Aber ich sollte das auch sagen, ja, wahrscheinlich.
Ja.
Wenn ich den Unfall gehört habe, sollte ich direkt sagen, ja, wahrscheinlich, okay, ich schließe sie an das Monitor an.
Ja, also, wo ich das eigentlich besonders spannend fand, weil ihrer, weil ihrer ja sehr interessanten Differenzialdiagnose oder eigentlich war das ja ihre Verdachtsdiagnose, dass der eine Lungenembolie hat.
Ja.
Das fordert natürlich relativ zügige Behandlungen.
Ja, ja, ja.
Tatsächlich sind hier in diesem Fall Beispiel, sind die auf die Spur gar nicht gegangen.
Die haben als Verdachtsdiagnose die Radiosfraktur rechts und ein stumpfes Torachstrauma angenommen, alternativ eine Rippenfraktur und eine Handgelenkdistortion.
Ja.
Ja, also, was denn jetzt wahrscheinlicher ist, das muss wahrscheinlich auch der Augenschein bringen.
Mhm.
Gut. Tatsächlich war hier jetzt noch eine Frage.
Ich hoffe, sie sind mir nicht böse.
Die Frage nach den sicheren Frakturzeichen.
Okay.
Bewegungsproblem, Hematom.
Das kann auch bei der, das kann auch bei der Distortion sein.
Okay, okay, Solution Distortion und Fraktur.
Also ich mache jetzt mal irgendwie so, ne?
Mhm.
Die Hand steht ganz komisch.
Fehlstellung.
Fehlstellung, ja, ja, mal Position.
Ja.
Dann ist natürlich das, was Sie vorgeschlagen haben, der Nachweis im Röntgen ist auch ein sicheres Frakturzeichen.
Und dann gibt es noch das, wo ich gar nicht drüber nachdenken will.
Ja, hören aber ein Geräusch, aber das Geräuschbar das.
Allein, ich habe immer schon Schwierigkeiten, das Wort überhaupt zu sagen.
Das tut es bei mir schon weh.
Krepitation.
Ja, Krepitation.
Ja, also ich finde, es knirscht schon und tut weh, wenn man nur das Wort ausspricht.
Ja, stimmt, genau.
Ja, also das sind die drei.
Ja, das ist der Nachweis.
Fehlstellung und Krepitation, das sind die sicheren Zeichen, dass da was durch ist.
Okay.
Ja, gerne.
Beziehungsweise Abnorme-Beweglichkeit haben die noch.
Also Fehlstellung oder Abnorme-Beweglichkeit.
Ja, wenn ich also meinen Finger so in alle Richtungen drehen kann,
dann ist ziemlich klar, dass da irgendwas durch ist.
Weil der kann eigentlich ja nur so.
Gut.
Aber eigentlich wurden wir nicht so viel bewegt und kehr.
Ja, genau.
Nach dem Unfall, ansonsten wird das.
Ja, ja, was die, was die jetzt tatsächlich auch noch gesagt haben.
Außer dem Röntgen, eine schnelle Voruntersuchung,
möglicherweise auch nicht blöde, wenn man, wenn man zu Ende denkt.
So nur Abdomen.
Also eine.
Ultraschall des Abdomens, um zu gucken, ob da eventuell freie Flüssigkeit ist.
Absolut.
Was ich meine, ist rechte Seite.
Milz ist eigentlich jetzt nicht in Gefahr.
Aber beim Brust sollen wir auch.
Ja, und zum Beispiel, ich glaube,
und man kann im Ursprachschall auf eine zusammengefallene Lunge drehen.
Oder Sie hören das in der Pallpation, dass Sie hören, dass da kein Schall mehr auf der Lunge ist,
wenn der einen Pfeurmotorachs hat.
Gerne, ja, ich denke.
Das wäre, ja, wobei, dann würde es dir nicht schlechter gehen.
Da würde ich ja nicht sagen, ich habe ein bisschen Schmerz in meinem einen Atmen.
Das ist also sehr weit hergeholt.
War nur hier als eine Alternative mit angegeben.
Ja, stimmt, genau.
Ja, ja.
Also ich hätte jetzt nicht gedacht, dass das Ihre erste ist.
Sie haben das sehr gut gemacht.
Wirklich, super.
Danke Ihnen, vielen Dank.
Und also insbesondere sprachlich, wobei Sie natürlich den großen, großen Vorteil haben,
Sie sind jeden Tag bei der Arbeit schon im Gespräch mit deutschen Muttersprachlern, oder?
Ja, oft ist das so.
Aber als Medizinisch kann ich noch nichts so sagen.
Ja, das ist ein Institut.
Und im Institut macht man immer Forschung.
Ja, und wahrscheinlich viel Englisch, oder?
Nicht so viel Englisch.
Ich sprach immer Deutsch.
Ja, aber das ist ja.
Seitdem ich hier gekommen bin, sprach ich immer Deutsch gesprochen.
Aber ja, die Begriffe sind ganz anders.
Das ist Akademische mit Begriffen.
Ja, wobei das ist ja eigentlich, also gerade für das Arzt-Arzt-Gespräch ist das ja eine super Krücke.
Ja, also die Fachterminologie ist ja wirklich, kann man sagen, weltweit identisch.
Und da kann man da auch viele Sachen zurückgreifen.
Schwierig ist das natürlich, wenn Sie einem Patienten irgendwas erklären sollen.
Da fehlen in möglicherweise die deutschen Begriffe.
Aber ich hatte nicht den Eindruck, dass Sie bei der Sprache Probleme haben.
Überhaupt nicht.
Wirklich nicht.
Danke, danke.
Also, ja, wann haben Sie Ihre Prüfung?
Ja, meine Prüfung ist am Anfang von Juni, im ersten Juni.
Im ersten Juni.
Ja, seid ihr sehr entspannt?
Ja, ich habe jetzt genug Zeit.
Ja, ich schau mal, ja, ich stehe für Schritt für Schritt.
Schau, ich schau mal die Fälle.
Eigentlich habe ich bisher
Magendar, Gastrointestinalfälle habe ich geschaut und Lungenfälle habe ich geschaut.
Daher ist es, aber noch nicht Unfall und so weiter auf der BDI.
Mit irgendwas fängt man an.
Ja, alles klar.
Gut, ja.
Alles klar.
Ich sage für heute schön Dank, Ihr Patient bedankt sich sehr für die freundliche Behandlung.
Und ich weiß nicht, ob Dr.
Günthes an Bord ist.
Mal gucken, ob er sich rührt.
Rührt sich nicht.
Er ist schon wieder abgetaucht hier.
Ja, also ich möchte vielleicht nur ganz schnell eben was erklären für alle, die sich etwas später eingeschaltet haben.
Ich war ein klein wenig Gehandik.
Und Sie haben das wahrscheinlich auch bemerkt, dass ich immer so in meinem Gesicht rumgefasst habe.
Ich habe heute Nachmittag ein Backenzahn rausgepult bekommen, und zwar in.